[Rhythmic office sounds]
Look at these people.
Is everyone at this company
clinically depressed?
Everyone here is hanging by a
thread.
They could snap at any moment.
[Gunshot sound] Bam!
[Screams]
We want to use you as our tools
in this situation.
Yes. Think of yourself as
tools.
You guys are tools.
The well being of our employees
is at an all time low.
These were all children once.
Happy, innocent children.
And now look at them.
Think of yourself as tools.
[Grunts]
-We're all just trying to fill
the void. -The void?
You know, the emptiness that
exists inside all of us.
Where are you getting all of
that cake from?
You guys are tools.
Question - why do you think it's
OK to come into work
with your shirt untucked?
Because life is meaningless and
nothing we do matters.
Think of yourself as tools.
Hey, Matt!
I thought you were dead, but
turns out
you're just sleeping on the
toilet.
Just stay back.
I'm going to kill myself.
Richard, we all want to kill
ourselves.
They're finally letting you guys
fire someone?
You're fired.
Congratulations!
The only way to beat the system
is to turn the system against
itself.
Are you PowerPoint proficient?
I'm more than proficient.
I listed it as a special skill
on my résumé.
We all know there's no God.
But there is a ton of money to
be made in his name.
I feel like we're experiencing
something really special.
What?
Got him!